clark county commissioner justin jones
he is
an avid bike rider represents the
southwest valley
one day after what took place yesterday
he wants all of us to be better and
safer on the road
we have kate houston live in the
newsroom with a conversation she had
with him earlier today
kate yes commissioner jones has been
cycling for 15 years
during that time he's worked closely
with local organizations to promote
safe riding here in southern nevada
jones says while there are laws to
protect cyclists
more needs to be done he says oftentimes
major changes aren't made until
after a tragedy happens much like the
one that occurred yesterday
jones wants motorists to understand that
cyclists have the right to be in the
lane of travel
and they should be given three feet of
room commissioner jones tells me the
cycling community in southern nevada is
very close
and what happened yesterday has had a
profound impact
yesterday was a tough day a lot of my
friends
uh who are cyclists it was just it's
it's a rough time
um you know they're one of my good
friends
uh he said he's he's likely done with
with uh road biking because of this
he unfortunately got hit by a motorist a
year or so ago
and uh you know we need to be able to to
to not
throw in the towel right we need to be
able to be in a situation where you can
feel safe
getting out there on on bikes because
it's it's what a lot of us love
right now commissioner jones is working
with the southern nevada bicycle
coalition
and ghost bikes to encourage safe
cycling
he wants southern nevadans to use this
as an opportunity to remind themselves
of the laws that are in place to protect
both drivers and cyclists
he tells me his heart is with the
families of those that died
and with those that were there to
witness what happened he's worried that
the trauma will be long lasting